it's been a safe assumption that
developer monolith have been working on
a follow-up to their 2014 Game of the
Year middle-earth
shadow of Mordor while it seems retailer
target may have leaked the game details
and release date of the still
unannounced game as spotted by neogaf
user death by backlog a listing for
middle-earth shadow of war appeared on
targets international website the since
removed listing featured box art along
with a short description and a release
date of August 22nd it reads go behind
enemy lines to forge your army conquer
fortresses and dominate Mordor from
within experience how the award-winning
Nemesis system creates unique personal
stories with every enemy and follower
and confront the full power of the Dark
Lord Sauron and his ring rates in this
epic new story of middle-earth details
on a gold edition of the game are also
listed in addition to the base game it
will apparently include two Nemesis
expansions slaughter tribe and outlaw
tribe featuring new enemies followers
missions abilities weapons fortress and
wilderness updates and a mythic gear set
it will also feature two new story
expansions called the blade of Galadriel
and the desolation of Mordor the Gold
Edition listing also gives a little more
detail on the game itself teasing the
ability to forge a new ring of power
conquer fortresses in massive battles
and dominate Mordor with your personal
or army this isn't the first mention of
a sequel to shadow of Mordor
early last year stunt performer lauren
mary kim's online resume mentioned she
worked on shadow of Mordor - for
everything middle-earth and all the
details on shadow of war as they arrived
hit subscribe if you're on YouTube and
keep it locked to GameSpot